i'm leanna Galera coming to you Ichi is
live at comic-con with the cast of arrow
this is a very bittersweet moment for me
I'm so excited that you guys are here
thank you so much for taking the time
out of your day but this is our last
arrow Comic Con interview how are you
feeling right now
see you then this is something that has
been part of your lives for such a long
time how does it feel being with the
fans at your last comic-con super
emotional last night was super emotional
it actually kind of caught me off guard
the number of people that came up and
someone came up to me there a director
on Supergirl
mostly and they like took like five
minutes to thank me which feels weird
for you know like getting their break on
arrow
it feels great I think it's I think that
the cast and the crew I think that it's
starting to feel like a little teensy
bit of a victory lap and it feels
awesome I was about to drop an f-bomb we
are gonna be getting quite a bit of
laughs in this last season of arrow but
we are getting a first Katie you are
stepping behind the camera to direct an
episode I am yeah so are we allowed to
say what happens yeah yes you know three
amazing um I actually started prep on
Tuesday oh very soon yeah I went over
this hiatus I did the Warner Brothers
directors program and it was incredible
I've you know I learned so much and and
I'm really excited it's gonna be awesome
obviously David you've directed before
do you have any advice to impart onto
Katie um yes settle don't give your
actors any kind of breaks
[Laughter]
ten episodes of arrow left and we have a
lot of ground to cover before we get
into the most ambitious crossover we've
ever done in the arrowverse let's start
from this what can you guys actually
tease about the new season and then
we'll work from there
take us off David me yeah I was gonna
say Steve and kick it teach with new
seasons I think it's a tribute
there's a certain amount of I like what
Stephen said in terms of a victory lap
you sense that there's be a lot of stuff
from the past I think there would be
some old faces that show up but I think
just in terms of the pacing I think it's
changed because we usually do this in 22
episodes and now we're doing a 10 so I
think you're just going to sense yeah I
feel like each episode is huge you know
I've read 1 2 & 3 1 2 & 3 are very
contained one is his own thing too is
its own thing 3 is its own thing
best of luck by the way nice it's very
very very contained
I'm obviously there's a through line and
we're building towards the crossover but
it's it's really fun and it's fun
working with some familiar faces too I
could say that Union you haven't seen
Renee this way in the very first episode
of seasoning well I was gonna say
because in our season finale we saw
Renee and we saw Diana really step away
in the future storyline they were gonna
go into hiding does this mean you guys
are gonna able to hide from having to go
through that aging make up love I don't
know actually I actually don't know the
answer to that but I
I don't actually love a deep it's not
great my face ages yeah yeah it's
painful but but it but it was very fun
because it's such a departure from what
you know you you play this character for
so long and then you can really like you
know jump and you see them in the future
and it's um it's like a pretty rich
thing as an actor so that was great but
I think we're gonna have a lot of leeway
to do a lot of different things with
that this year
well you guys have mentioned that we
could be seeing some familiar faces
popping back up I need to know if we
will be getting the lovely Emily better
cards back in this final-season Steven
no that's true that's true um I know
that you still keep in touch with Emily
how she doing do you send her your love
does she know about you either New York
Times review of her she's like what is
your play next Sunday I'm excited she's
doing great
we miss her a lot online I was very I
was I was actually my tested her when I
was on the plane to Vancouver last week
and I just text her that I was sad
there's the show feels different in you
know no small part because and that's
not with this anymore those different
well David Katie and Stephen you guys
have been part of the series since the
pilot when you look back at that pilot
what do you remember most about your
first day of shooting first day I
remember calling Donald was in who's in
the premiere which is amazing his only
job for that first day of shooting was
to lay unconscious on a slab of concrete
and that guy stuck around the entire day
just to watch and I remember
yeah I felt nicely trying to hold it
together so just like stressed out and
scared sorry never being a hold it
together
please don't get fired I really want
this job it seems like this is gonna be
really awesome and it doesn't so you
know I just got those first day of
school nerves out during them going on
the street after our little scene we
shot the little thing and I diner was
not her yeah David nutter our gender
directed the pilot with wonderful
director I remember being on the street
with him and another producer and him
standing on the street with me saying
this is gonna be a huge show and me and
the other producers say no don't jinx it
don't jinx it he's like no it's gonna be
a huge huge show it's like something he
knew so I'm like I saw we were thinking
maybe just maybe first table read and I
don't know if you've done I think I
might have said this said this to you
before but I actually because there's
such there was such a relationship
between Laurel obviously and Oliver I
you were never scripted as Olly I just
threw it in there and then they started
writing it so because I wanted them to
have like a nickname you know other
things that I remember from the pilot is
you and I shot the scene in front of the
globe in the Convention Center downtown
and one of our executive producers
texted both of us afterwards and the tax
just said you were both born to play
Oliver Queen and Laurel Lance remember
that yeah
oh I just got chills yeah as we wrap it
up we are gonna have our most ambitious
crossover we've ever had on this show
what can you tease for the fans out
there I know that there's still so much
that's clouded in secrets but what can
you tell us yes I'm gonna play more than
one character over okay keep going I'm
messing up no I'm gonna play more than
one character in the crossover yeah can
you tell me who they're all named Oliver
oh thanks getting different earths
Oliver's I like it
no no no baby
[Music]